okay today I'm going to talk to you
about visible light so visible light is
a part of the electromagnetic spectrum
as you can see it sits right in the
middle of the electromagnetic spectrum
in between ultraviolet and infrared all
of the types of it electromagnetic
radiation that side have a higher
frequency and all the ones that side
have a lower frequency now visible light
is the only part of the electromagnetic
spectrum that we can actually see is the
only one only type of waves within there
there are eyes can actually detect all
of the rest of the waves our eyes cannot
detect so if we have a bit closer look
at the visible light spectrum we can see
that it's split into these separate
components based on the different
wavelengths so the different colors are
red orange yellow green blue indigo and
violet now there's a nice way remember
in it we imagine a character whose name
is Roy G Biv that's Roy G Biff then we
could remember the particular order of
the different parts of the visible light
spectrum what I've done next to each one
is I've drawn a diagram to show the
difference in wavelength between each
one as you can see red is the part of
the visible light spectrum with the
greatest wavelength whereas if we go all
the way down as we go further this way
we can see the wavelengths get shorter
and shorter until we get to violet
now let's think about what that means
with relation to the rest of the
electromagnetic spectrum so if we were
here this is where red appears in the
visible light spectrum it would be on
this side of visible light spectrum if
we increase the wavelength of red any
further
ittan we can no longer see it that wave
would now be classed as infrared and
we'd no longer be able to see it so
remember that red is on this side
because infrared just means
below kind of a greater wavelength of an
read so that is what we're read would
fit in
conversely if we've got violent with the
shortest wavelength that would be on the
other side of the visible light spectrum
over here if we had a wave with a
slightly shorter wavelength and violet
we would no longer would be no longer so
sorry we've been no longer able to see
that and it would now be ultraviolet
radiation or ultraviolet wave instead
and we would no longer be able to see it
so the different parts of the visible
light spectrum transfer different
amounts of energy violet transfers more
energy than any of the others okay
there's a couple of other things we need
to know about visible light so first of
all just like all of the other parts of
the electromagnetic spectrum
they are transverse waves also just like
the other parts of the electromagnetic
spectrum the speed of light is around
not exactly but around 300 million
meters per second in a vacuum now we
just quickly need to have a look at the
use of a visible light the main use is
in photography now we can kind of split
that down into two little subsections
because visible light is required in
both photographic film because what
happens is what happens is it reacts to
light the photographic film reacts to
light in order to fill a form an image
so that's how it's used in photographic
film the second way is digital cameras
so visible light can also be used in
digital cameras because digital cameras
contain image sensors which detect
visible light and generate an electrical
signal this signal is converted into an
image that could be stored digitally or
printed so essentially that's all we
need to know about visible light thank
you